you
Latin nouns used case endings to mark
the nouns function in a sentence take
the name Brutus as a subject it's in the
nominative case
Brutus became brutal as an object it's
in the accusative case the Romance
languages ditched this case system over
the centuries but the few lingering
remnants are worth our attention the
basic form of a noun
comes from the accusative case we saw
that last time
so nominative morose isn't the source of
italian moodle French mu Romance me etc
those all come from the accusative
Moodle which became vulgar latin moodle
that's the general historical trend but
there are exceptions
old French held onto the nominative for
quite a while
take the latin noun lupus which meant
wolf and the accusative form of it was
Lupul old french distinguished the
nominative loops from an accusative loop
still the push to simplify was very
strong and even modern French today just
has grew the difference between
nominative and accusative matters in the
plural not in any single Romance
language but across the family Eastern
Romance languages take their plural
forms from the Latin nominative so
vulgar latin lupo with the nominative
plural loopy gives us Italian Lupo and
loopy the Western Romance languages hold
on to the accusative plural instead so
Lupo with the accusative plural Lupo's
gives us Sardinia Lupo and lupus romance
roof and loose for wolf and wolves
what about the other latin cases besides
nominative and accusative for the most
part they died out romanian languages
including standard romanian i Romanian
and related languages have endings
combining the genitive and dative cases
what are those the genitive is like a
possessive as in the wolf's bone and the
dative indicates a recipient to the wolf
Romanian Casa has a genitive dative form
Casa but I usually see these Romanian
genitive dative nouns with a definite
article articles didn't even exist in
classical Latin lupus meant wolf a wolf
or the wolf depending on context vulgar
latin speakers innovated articles
specifically the word aloo accusative
case masculine gender for that came to
mean thee with masculine nouns just as
allah did with feminine nouns illa Lupo
Italian e Lupo French Lulu Catalan a
yoke or Allah Casa which gave us words
like Italian La Casa Galician and
Portuguese whittled the definite
articles down to just who and ah as you
see it's important to know the gender of
your nouns the gender of the article
matches the nouns gender Sardinian and
Balearic Catalan used EEP soup the same
word we find a nip so factor so it's e
su Lupo sulu poo and his job we find the
feminine was ISA so Sardinian in Catalan
suck in Romanian definite articles
attached to the end of a noun loop we
loo not illa Lupo explains Romanian
loophole and Casa Allah becomes Casa
the plurals of these definite articles
mimic the nouns they sit near by now you
know that Lupo has the plural loopy in
the East but lupus in the West and Casa
has the plural Casa in the East but
casts us in the West you probably even
remember why it's no surprise then then
Alou Lupo has the plural elos lupus in
the West Los Lobos Lu is loose which low
Bush or that illa loopy remains in the
East a loopy in Italian and loopy in
Romanian
languages unanimously use the word 1 for
the indefinite article
oh no Lupo
una Casa
the plural sum is dealt with in various
ways many languages allow the bear noun
Iberian languages like Spanish may use
the plural of one to mean son unos lobos
bouche la bouche french and oxygen used
the latin word day which means some of
or some they loop Romanians can use
nishta as in niche de loop Romance
languages are often skittish about bare
nouns especially as subjects we see
Sardinia salut post or italian e loopy
where english has just wolves it's also
true of bear singulars expect vulgar
latin la giustizia italian la giustizia
french logistics all meaning v justice
instead of the noun for justice by
itself that French and oxygen article
with de is an instance of a positive
article you'll also find it in Italian
do that del vino means somewhat blue van
even mean wine in general it's an
innovation you won't find in languages
along the periphery Spanish Portuguese
or Romanian for instance last back to
those Romanian articles and that curious
genitive dative case Romanian nouns tack
an article to their back as an ending
we've already seen that with loophole
and loopy that ending changes in the
genitive dative loop loop 1 loop lui
if you've been following along and maybe
taking notes over the last two videos
you have some understanding of how nouns
work in the Romance languages we're
going to build on that but next time we
focus our attention on verbs